للمره الاولى منذ عام 2011 تاريخ اندلاع
الثوره السوريه بدات انقره ودمشق بعمليه
كسر الجليد بينهما ومحاوله تجاوز العداء
والقطيعه السياسيه لكن الطريقه تبدو طويله
ويشوبها الكثير من العقبات والتساؤلات حول
النوايا ايضا بدء بالملفات العالقه في
شمالي سوريا وشروط التطبيع السياسي اضافه
الى شقوق حول مرحله هذه الخطوات كانت
تكتيكيه ام استراتيجيه مد اردوغان يده
للاسد من اجل ما سماه السلام في المنطقه
مؤشر كاف على استعداد انقره لاستئناف
العلاقات مع دمشق خطواتنا اعتبرها تقرير
لصحيفه الفينال تايمز البريطانيه ضربه
للمعارضه السوريه
تحديدا الفصائل المسلحه الموجوده في ادلب
التي ترجمتعاضها من التقارب التركي
السوريه بالمظاهرات والنزول الى الشارع
ربما لانه لم يعد يوجد سبيل امامها سوى
اعاده تاكيد دعم انقره لها من جديد بعد ان
كانت حليفتها الاقوى الى جانب ما تبقى من
المعارضين داخل تركيا نفسها
للقوات الكرديه في سوريا ايضا حصه وفره من
الضرر قد يكون على حساب مصالحها في حال
التوصل لاي اتفاق بين البلدين خصوصا انها
تتمتع بحكم ذاتي تقرير الصحيفه الغربيه
اضاف ان لدى اردوغان دوافع داخليه ربما
تتجلى بقضيه اللاجئين في حين ان المصالحه
الكامله ستكون عمليه طويله وصعبه وحتى لو
تم التوصل الى اتفاق من غير المرجح ان
يغادر اللاجئون تركيا بسرعه اما دوافع
اردوغان الاخرى وبحسب الصحيفه فتتمر
باستغلاله الورقه السوريه لتقويه حظوظه
بالفوز بالانتخابات الرئاسيه